Good evening and welcome to Deep Search.
That was Charles Aznavour singing "Happy Birthday."
You can probably guess why I opened the show with that.
I think many of you already know, but tonight, exactly at midnight, we cross into February 1st,
and me, right there, I go over the other side of the mountain.
I turn sixty.
Yeah, the big six-oh.
The kind of thing that stings your eyes a little, if we're honest.
So tonight, this is a special broadcast.
That's why we shifted the show to this late slot.
Since it's my birthday, and not just any birthday, I had to mark the moment and offer you a different kind of show.
In 1966, Johnny was singing "Black Is Black."
Hendrix was singing "Hey Joe."
Nancy Sinatra was singing "Bang Bang."
And Carla Thomas was singing this one.
Carla Thomas was singing "Baby."
I arrived in 1966.
So opening with a track from '66 called "Baby" just makes sense.
Tonight, we're going to hear a lot of music.
A lot, a lot, truly a lot.
With the playlist I've built for you, we're spending the whole night together.
Yes, you heard me right.
I'm playing music for you all the way until sunrise.
We're going to travel back through time, musically, from 1966 to 2026.
Every track I picked resonates with me in a very personal way.
You never really know why one song marks you more than another,
but tonight I'm taking the chance to play only the records that I absolutely love.
And because music has that power to call back memories of a moment, a place, or a person,
tonight I'll play music all night and tell you stories.
The magic of songs that touch us lets our adventures stay printed in memory forever.
And of course, given my path, many of my memories are tied to one place that means the world to me:
the dance floor.